cool thank you everybody I am here to
present about insights in 5D uh we have
a little bit of a wizard and Magic theme
just like the magic that got the slides
onto the screen so uh I'm going to talk
through small multiple layouts um my
name is Matt Dugan I've never worn one
of those hats but I did on this slide I
am the director of data at a PR software
company called mukra and I live not far
from right
here before we get started or kind of as
an intro we'll start off with a with a
question um I want you guys to look at
this visualization I did not create this
is a great visualization from Twitter
um I want you to tell me what you learn
from this graphic I realized it's a
little small but those are each uh from
the early days of Co they're different
US states and you can see how they're
progressing I think in the first three
three or four months of the
pandemic so you can think to yourself
what sort of things do you learn from
this plot look at the different states
but then if I apply some of my wizard
magic and just rearrange where the
states are um you might learn something
different or you might find it a little
more easy to walk away with some some
insights from this and let's just think
about quickly to get to the clickbait
title 5D we have time on one a we have
number of cases on another axis then
like latitude and longitude are sort of
at play in here as another couple of
Dimensions there's also color so I
promise we are in 5D here a little bit
now this is actually using a package
called U Geo facet which some of you may
have been familiar with but I want you
to walk away with one thing the layout
of those little facets it matters it
helps make uh it more easy for your
audience to to walk away with some
insight so we're going to be talking
about these layouts but before we get
into it I want to do a quick recap on
facets and small multiples in R and how
we interact with these so let's just
revisit our favorite uh Iris data set
here's a simple scatter plot of seel
length versus seel width I don't know
what those are but uh we all know the
data well I can use uh what's called
facet wrap which will give me one little
panel or one facet one little graph for
each of the uh Iris species those are
also three words that I've never said
out loud in my life and today will not
be the first day that I do that um then
there's also facet grid which is a
little different it relies on
categorical data in this particular case
I added columns called uh pedal what do
I call it here like the pedal width
class and it's splitting up into cases
where the pedal is wide or thin this is
in order to use facet grid you have to
have these
categorical um features like this now
what I want to do is I want to use a
little bit more of an exciting data set
kind of something a little bit geog
graphical like the uh like the US Co
case we were looking at earlier let's
look at um some us election data so what
I've done is I've taken all of the
counties in the state of California and
I don't you need you don't need to read
this whole thing it's not a course on
how to make GG plots but what you should
see is that we're doing facet wrap on
the county name and what you can see is
just like with the iris data sets each
county is arranged alphabetically now it
might be a little tricky to take away
any insights the alphabetical sorting of
the counties is not really related to
anything we know of in real life we
don't see the counties in alphabetical
order so this is where the magic of
facet warp comes in what if I want to
warp them I add these two parameters the
macro X the macro y to sort them in the
big picture by longitude and latitude
what you can see now here is that each
of the little facets is sorted like a
little mini map of California if you
really squint you can sort of see the
shape of California it's also no
coincidence to the uh political
enthusiasts that the blue ones are along
the west coast and some of the more red
ones are a little bit uh further Inland
these are just the Geo demographic
patterns of California now unlike uh the
Geo faet package I didn't have a
pre-canned layout of these counties this
was computed magically on the Fly given
longitude and latitude so since these
are just numerical columns I can
actually do this with other data what if
I wanted to do it by population density
or median age think of plotting each
county in California by their population
density or their age I can take this
layout and snap it to the grid that's
exactly what this is see how San
Francisco is on the right Sierra is up
at the top left that's exactly what this
is doing um so this can be a fun way uh
maybe not always great for you know
Publications cuz some of the text can be
a little small but I like to use this
for exploring data to help me learn
about what's going on in the data here's
another giant one of all the L stops
here in Chicago wanted to do a thematic
one for those who do know the LA layout
you would remember that the O'Hare stop
is kind of way far away from all the
other stops you can see these patterns
spatially uh which is pretty cool um
there's a paper here that explains that
algorithm that how the snapping happens
I won't go into the details but it's
from 1987 this is all culminating in the
fact that I actually just released this
package um and it's called facet warp so
you guys can all look at it it's a punon
facet wrap but in this case facet warp
thank
[Applause]
you